let's turn to a new online scam
targeting restaurants across the country
it has the potential to hurt their
bottom line and potentially scare away
diners so scammers are leaving fake one
star reviews then demanding payment to
remove them federal agencies are looking
into this it's one more problem for
restaurants still recovering from the
pandemic and facing rising prices janet
chameleon shows us what one top
restaurant went through in texas
are everywhere on your phones in your
emails and one scam
could actually be influencing where you
choose to eat
the target restaurants that rely on
customer reviews and that's almost all
of them
the swindle demand a ransom forcing
restaurants to pay up or face a barrage
of bad reviews
thank you for calling
how may i help you houston restaurant
blue door and is often mentioned as one
of the city's best but you wouldn't know
it by some of the one-star reviews
posted recently on google hey jeff where
are these from co-owner and chef aaron
bludorn says they all appeared at the
same time when you first saw those
negative reviews what did you think i
was heartbroken that that someone was
you know taking something that we've
worked so hard for which were you know
plenty of four-star five-star reviews
and a good rating on google and they
knocked us down
ludoran and co-owner sharif mooch
say before this they rarely receive
negative feedback how concerned were you
very concerned a reputation for
restaurant is everything
they learned the reviews were part of a
scam after the restaurant says it
received an untraceable email asking for
a 75 dollar google play gift card to
have them taken down
did you ever consider
paying the quote ransom or the gift card
i i didn't consider ever paying that
that ransom because to me that meant
that they would have you know
won
and been able to you know i also didn't
know where it would end the note said in
part
negative feedback about your
establishment has been left by us and
will appear in the future
one review a day
restaurants across the country are
reporting similar extortion threats
first a barrage of bad reviews then a
request for money in the form of a gift
card to stop them anyone that thinks
that they can put these bad reviews on
and see if they can do a little shake
out of restaurants need to realize that
they're committing a crime michelle
corsmo of the national restaurant
association says federal agents are now
investigating the cyber criminals she
encourages more awareness among diners
you know consumers should really read
reviews with a critical eye to see if
they make sense with what others have
said about the restaurant don't let a
swindler scam you out of a great
restaurant experience bluedorn says it
reached out to google which initially
said the one star reviews didn't violate
policy because there were no comments
included the restaurant then posted the
blackmail attempt on its social media to
explain what happened and was
overwhelmed when more than 100 customers
submitted their own google reviews
owning a small business i decided to go
write a review because reviews are so
very important to
getting everyday customers new to come
in a google spokesperson tells cbs news
the company's teams are working around
the clock to thwart these attacks remove
fraudulent reviews and put protections
on business profiles that may have been
affected and later google did in fact
remove the reviews both the bad ones and
the good ones it seems the way google
fixed it was they look at the range of
which this incident had occurred and
just took out all the reviews so the one
star reviews along with all the hundreds
of good reviews that we've accumulated
over a period of time
bluedorn says it never lost customers
but it happened at a challenging time
it's not only you know are we dealing
with inflation and less guess demand but
we're also dealing with it on our side
with inflation and we can't really raise
our prices because we want to stay
competitive so
every guest counts right now battling
bogus ratings as a restaurant defends
its reputation
for cbs mornings i'm janet chamleon in
houston
this is a prime example why it's
important to post a good review if you
love a place that way it overshadows
some of these phony ones